previously on satisfactory and now
continuing whoa man I can't believe how
long those yellow slugs take the harvest
I felt bad leaving you there for so long
yeah yeah that's weird what'd it take
like five minutes man you were there you
were gone a while
I have a pretty warped perception of
time it was more like four minutes and
57 seconds oh yeah you know I always
keep exaggerating like that it's a story
of my life I'm just an [ __ ] chad is
like man wait till you find the bigger
ones apparently the fires not the
scariest element is news least we know
that mark could run team distraction
I didn't hear the end of that but I'm
assuming it was only glowing happiness
for me and who I am still birds you can
run this stretch it's funny when I'm in
pain
yeah you know now now that we're through
that I just feel like I don't like you I
mean I didn't die no we killed the
monster and you unfortunately missed the
month shockingly we somehow killed the
thing what are we building next I'm just
all about getting this biofuel going you
now we need to research the tier three
apparently as what's always saying okay
we've got tons of materials so we can
probably do a bunch of like random
[ __ ] let me I'm gonna go ahead and
dump in these I can I've got enough of
this no missing two cables where's my
cables got it you got him yep the button
all right man good press how sweet it
was yeah and how much how many I guess
it wasn't that important huh oh wow I
can't believe we're working on this I
took a piss in my vibrator
[Laughter]
really wait really everyone understands
we all know we've been there we don't
either Oh Dale ah yeah I get it I'm
gonna set these mini miners to work
while comforts y'all right there yeah
I'm fine
you sure I just I just I I yeah I just
needed a moment holy [ __ ] [ __ ] Jesus
Christ huh
what should we go for next are we just
trying to do upgrades I'm building a
fortress okay come in that's all right
Oh their stairs oh [ __ ] guys the
fortress of Baba - diz coming together
shut up
that's hilarious not hilarious it's
terrifying it's really funny you will
fear me all right yeah good good good
all right oh that's a little short so
look at my dope fortress myself I made
stairs inside
[Laughter]
[Music]
so I made these stairs and then I walked
up and I was just like that's what Bob
does he runs off he builds a tree house
all right good good luck with that I'm
gonna keep trying to build our base up
responsibly unless you be part of our
base no he's right no it's daily part of
our base I mean it's part of your base
not part of my base this part about we
are a collective we don't need you I'm
building a second expansion and I'm
gonna take some biofuel from your lovely
biofuel creator I'm glad you like it I'm
glad you like it
it is very lovely what do you fantastic
is it not wages we all pull it out our
arse wait don't pull out your biofuel
creator please for the love it's my way
with you
[Laughter]
hey I need to smelt some of this card
under crateria down into Wired materia I
don't know or nor do I care how oh hell
no boss
I won't I'm not going to Falls I know no
balls no balls
I have none and flavor that also makes
babies go pop don't don't vibrate rose
cause you knows that's what you need to
stop
look my fortress is coming together the
prison it's my fortress no the top the
top is nice Bob are so close to the
whisker moth though can i zaps chicken
come here what makes noise wow what are
you talking about ran up with the
insects incest I don't know what your
the [ __ ] you're talking about listen
love huncles I don't know what you're
trying to say here but uh we have fun
here whatever their can say okay we do
have fun here I really wished I could
have shade saw this tree out of my face
before it happened but whatever I can
build a storage container in here I've
doubled our supply of iron derivatives
production you all should worship me as
a god wait what I'm waiting this is
gonna take longer than I'm implying but
I have an idea and I want to try it okay
something's about to go down mark okay
why me specifically I'm gonna
consolidate all mark it's going down on
you I'm gonna consolidate all of our
storage containers into one storage unit
inside the base why would you do that
because I want to
I need it for my research research
reason search it's fine everything's
fine
this is quite the base you have I will
admit it's quite the base just wait wait
till it has stuff in it your [ __ ]
then you'll see you mean all of our
stuff is half what you mail it's
happening now it's happening oh yeah
can't grab it off the conveyor it's
impossible it can't be grabbed oh I can
grab it never fine I'll let it happen
let it happen why do I sound a high
every time I [ __ ] talk I don't know
man
are you what's happening no wait wait
let it happen well I'm letting it happen
let it happen wait it's all I'm letting
it happen oh you should let it happen
where's the stuff from the what now you
sound drunk there's a lot of supplies on
this platform no it's fun it's fun this
is how it's supposed to be hanging on
that platform for I need to do I'm
consolidating everything okay I'm
Katella I'd be a problem why would it be
a problem why would this be a problem
this seems fine to me well I mean what
is it gonna do for in there be
consolidated you keep saying
consolidation you're like a business
that's doing a hostile takeover right
now it's gonna be consolidated you know
what maybe you might be a little bit
right there
okay well it is consolidating it nice
yeah its consolidating so if you need
resources wait
look I unlocked a milestone no I did
that I just did no I did not enjoy
working here trying to make you look
better is extra iron [ __ ] you've
actually been doing things do you think
I was lying of course I've been doing
things I'm over here just consolidating
suffering I've been wasting our slugs
that's true weight has been wasting the
slugs are you still slamming those slugs
in there what am I talking about
slamming reflected I just need the quick
wire and the fabric do we have an open
smelter I could use no no we have an
open crafting bench crafting bench a
crafting bench in here I will zap you oh
no all the irons been consolidated my
plan it's happening horrible horrible
plan you wanted it's the plan we needed
wait mark we're not making plates
anymore where's our iron plate
manufacturing we are making plates oh
god damn it they're all on the stupid
[ __ ] conveyer belt no good solid a
[Laughter]
smelter I mean where's our smelter
there's like a dozen smelters are you
stealing all of the iron so that I
wanted to use what I need you to build a
smelter right where you're standing
what No would you build your own build a
smelter right here please why should I
ask nicely please do it now all right
that's good enough that's pretty nice
how does this work is it working you
need to power it don't take let me do
the power I don't want you to even touch
the power don't
don't touch anything
hang on I don't need it I don't need it
don't say it
well hit on it you can only make a copy
of it iron ingots I can't make the catty
reom yet what why did I build it I don't
know you destroy it what did you think
was gonna happen oh maybe progress maybe
Wade would contribute to this and some
we're just building all the [ __ ]
conveyor belts in the house okay there
we go okay iron bars rods rods no all
right good talk I'm just saying there's
a lot of iron plates here not so many
rods Hey well I'm not even using the
rods I don't know who's taking the rods
hmm I mean I am now but you right who's
right about balls
you okay man I'm honestly starting to be
concerned dude I'm fine I'm just very
interested in my work do we need to call
somebody
Milas I finished consolidating I can my
job is done I can rest what do you mean
your job is done we haven't even gotten
even remotely close to being done
they're done consolidating my job is
done
we haven't I'm sorry did I stutter
you've got so many lots of iron plates
and reinforced iron plates over your
prompt oh thanks guys oh my god I just
need some [ __ ] plates oh there are no
plates coming to you could I just stole
them
I'm just stealing your plates you steal
him off the conveyor belt I sure AM oh
[ __ ] you important work to do
no you do not more than mine oh it's
much more important I'm making walkways
you swine my Empire no I'm not cuz I'm
trying to figure something out you see
all the consolidation that's going don't
I'm gonna come over there and I'm gonna
be mad but right now I'm being mad at
myself because I can't figure this out
oh you're just [ __ ] around with power
and [ __ ]
don't [ __ ] around with power I'm okay
sir fine cool
good plan to build an iron Empire here
all right I'm trying to make it so that
we have production out the ass I mean
that is pretty cool all right let me see
what you got yeah you only see what you
got going on huh all right this come to
me come to me come to me did you know
that you can stack storage containers
did you know that did you know that I
didn't actually know that that's pretty
cool yeah it's pretty cool all right let
me see we differ you got oh my god
everything will be consolidated oh my
god mark it's good it's really good
trust me Oh makes it really hard to rob
my god no mark it's cool it's a whole
there's a sequence of things that
happens it's really cool it's so slow
are we not making it is reinforced iron
place is really slow but you have to see
how far away you go so you saw I have
one up at the copper this goes this way
right right right it's got the biofuel
and round this quarter and you stole
from my shipping containers containers
if you want me to consolidate Oh guy
wasn't even done with the other ones out
I'm still working oh it's really slow
but just imagine when all this stuff is
all in one container how convenient
that's gonna be am i right I'm gonna
have to run over into your base knock on
your door Glick guess if you're gonna
actually
in the sauna door it's open okay yeah
but when we get door technology the code
to my door my man dunno we'll leave
someplace I'm really having a tough time
robbing you guys all that time I was
yelling about consolidating for like 40
minutes once you see it with your own
eyes you don't realize just how bad it
talks about it no one ever does anything
about it oh my god we didn't do anything
I guess I can't be mad cuz it's not
stealing we're working together right
working together to take your goddamn
iron place what does that sound that
you're making mark no I'm just breathing
why what's the problem
look out it's our you'd see the full
extent of all of the consolidation
that's going on I don't want our
production lines are too slow Oh mark
look at the pink sunset weights I stole
from Martin
we are consolidated goods march around
and straight little lines so hello it's
fine it's it's a it's a it's a long-term
process you know it's not fuel aren't
even able to get in we can build that
how do we build that oh we can build it
do we have enough for this Bob go raise
your supplies what do we need we need
250 plates
500 concrete four hundred rods 1500 wire
I think we have a hundred wire you know
we have I think we have that let me go
there are no plates there are plates you
idiot all right I have 70 iron plates
how many we need 250 I've got 116 myself
Wady rods I have 100 cables 100 concrete
and 31 plates we might be really close
on the plates actually I think we've got
the place how much of each thing we have
here Bob you take consolidating what are
we building special space elevator all I
need is rods like 210 rod okay rods fine
iron ingots and cram them into rocks oh
my god it's really [ __ ] big oh my god
oh my god oh my god oh oh holy [ __ ] holy
sweet Jesus that's big okay well I guess
that's good look out flying bird oh wow
where's the rocket part oh and oh [ __ ]
what's happening okay it's opening oh
wait look up whoa it's there's a thing
up there what is that
it's a rod Oh daddy holy [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh
my god oh I get it cuz it's a space
elevator
it goes to space oh wow I want to go I
want to go I want to go I don't think
you can go I want to go okay we need 50
rotors and 75 reinforced plates to do
something okay I super have to go it's
way later alright I'm supposed to be
getting off of here
I'm glad I got to see that I guess but
now it is time bye friends okay mark we
need to unconsolidated I don't know I
hate you don't break my [ __ ] I we can't
break his [ __ ] we just can't do that to
him you mean the [ __ ] he'd stole from
you can't he didn't steal he's
consolidating I get that I see the
wisdom in the plan now oh I'm glad I
have a great view of that space yeah
that's okay how do we ride the elevator
I don't think we can I want to go to
space so how do I go to space all right
we can we can we can launch that that we
can launch that thing we can do that do
you have 50 rotors and 75 reinforced
iron no but we can make it it's not that
hard I know you've never made a single
thing in this cake I'm still harvesting
limestone by hand and making concrete
for you I know you haven't actually
contributed yet but remember the plates
I stole I put those toward the walkway
uh-huh uh-huh uh-huh
now listen I'm pretty much a
professional I can tell and I found the
did you just come grab these plates no
you did you just grab these plates for a
long time I've only got 31 still no
because it went out of power that's
right then what caused it
ha good [ __ ] boy don't say those words
to me ever again
all right get sexed boy oh yeah that's
much better thank you so to make a road
or we need rods and screws holy [ __ ] we
need a lot of screws I'm gonna go grab
from Bob's grand consolidation they're
really
that much consolidated in here god damn
it oh my god lines are standing still
right now because of the slow
consolidation yep I really do think this
is a problem it is great in theory and
it's horrible to watch in practice yes
yes it is yes the worst thing I've ever
watched in my life how many of rotors
did we need 75 50 really just 50 50
rotors 75 reinforced iron plates oh [ __ ]
I got it backwards well alright well we
need a lot more reinforced iron plates
how many do you got none but you have 34
screws all right that's not a lot can
you just grab or start smelting it into
ironing it must take this alright thanks
I know this is gonna be the most
underwhelming thing when we actually get
this should I grab the ore from this
conveyor belt maybe everything was going
great until we consolidated it really
was everything was fine everything was
totally fine as soon as big Bob's
business came in and do the hostile
takeover Sallah dated everything did you
know you're not wrong you you are
actually quite right it was going so
fast we're making so much all we have to
do is undo his consolidation alright you
want to do that cuz I am oh I want you
to do it so I don't get blamed for what
he's stealing from you he's not stealing
from me he's fine wait I don't care what
you do I'm almost done
just go on your way go on my way go on
your winds my hub your hub okay alright
you up this up alright yeah I can't
before you Bob good it's true yes you do
like to swoop in at the last moment and
steal the credit I get that about you my
goal but the credit is mine I know it is
craft bench is occupied go to the
digital yeah let me go to the
consolidation booth over here to start
the goddamn space elevator what's wrong
with the space elevator oh my goodness I
am 15 away I am now 10 I need 10
reinforced plates can you make 10
reinforced plates no there's no way
I'll try do I need to make regular
plates first yes you need plates then
screws twenty four screws four plates I
might be done before you I'm gonna go
rob Bob again have you checked the
intermediary storage containers for the
proper supplies because those still do
no did not do that those are also an
option yeah they sure are all right I
got sixty three dick funguses there's no
iron plates and a goddamn container real
plates have made where are all the
plates consolidated somewhere
oh they oh my god they're way over here
I guess a hundred plates wow we did it
we really did it I'm so proud of you
thanks man
I'm lost where's our there's giant
needle so hole must be this way hey I
found it hey I'm done okay I'm gonna go
[Laughter]
here we go here you want to push the
lever you want to steal the credit and
push the lever you want to do it hang on
I let me get a good view you get to pull
it but I get to go up in the observation
okay that's fair right that's fine you
ready no I'm not ready don't pull it
don't you dare I'm not in a good feeling
it unseal it
Perrin wait wait is it moving oh oh
markets going what's happening okay what
where I'm ready okay where I don't see
what's happening we're sending oh okay
all right well is it all right oh [ __ ]
Oh goodbye we can't ride it man I can't
do it it's not writable
so why did we do that um to unlock tier
three in foreign research so we can
continue on this hellhole path of
construction that we've made for
ourselves oh no [ __ ] Tier three good
solid goddamn nation
oh wait if we deliver again we unlock
tier five and six
oh wow we need a hundred and fifty
motors of which I have personally
already contributed like seventeen and
five hundred modular frames of which I
have done not [ __ ] 400 quid wire hey
quick wire
oh [ __ ] be sorry boys I need that Teddy
on you can cerium ingots cataria more
man this is some good stuff a gun nice
you okay you know you alright yeah yeah
you know seems so good happy oh okay
cool alright it's it's a deer iam I
don't know ordinarily at this point we'd
have a much better production line I
think you know what wait wait wait wait
listen stop hold on wait and stop please
stop
no that's too late for me stop you don't
know about chance stop you don't know
how to build a business you've never
built one before you don't know you
don't know what you're doing I've got
this no you don't know there's one thing
I've got it's this buddy okay all right
I'll leave you with this then I gotta
get going no lightning this business
there's been enlightening look don't no
no no no no dude areum well I mean we're
pretty far we need a lot more stuff and
I don't think this 45 runners buddy just
know that you have it why right now
we're say 25 rotors I think you make the
road solvate the Earth's rotor my funny
like we used to do buddy if I keep
saying buddy you'll sell through the
road
[Laughter]
[Music]